[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission préférée à 6 ans par les sports
ce talk est consacré et comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive du
département
pendant une heure il y aura des coups de
gueule des analyses des débats et des
duels pour faire vivre cette émission
quatre chroniqueurs sont en plateau ils
sont coupables d'être les quatre plus
grands spécialistes du sport yvelinois
en activité leur présentation en musique
on commence à ma droite je vais vous
dresser sa fiche d'identité c'est un
pistard de niveau international il a été
vice champion du monde de cyclisme sur
piste au master's gilles est également
champion d'europe est adepte des sports
extrêmes et notamment de roller le
capitaine yann dujarrier est avec nous
pour cette émission
bonjour jan 11 ans michael or quand
allez-vous très bien très bien pour
cette émission
alors on va parler box handball football
bon il y aura un peu de tout ça vous
convient j'aime le plus long de toute
façon donc on est là pour parler de
sport vous allez chevalière louis
toujours un petit peu on passe à notre
deuxième chroniqueur c'est un cavalier
international vient tout droit de
plaisir et n'hésite pas à chercher le
duel au galop quand il le faut on le
surnomme sur ce plateau le zorro heavy
noir à vous et d'autre et est
avec nous pendant une heure bonjour
raoul jean michaël ça fait plaisir de
vous revoir et sur cette émission
n'était pas la dernière fois
non maintenant malheureusement j'ai les
empêchements parfois j'ai toujours aussi
heureux de revenir à chaque fois alors
pas d'équitation aujourd'hui en mai de
la bogue et de la boxe du coup vu que
événement de boxe dans le noble art donc
on n'a pas dire une pratique en loisirs
et en compétition et sans compétition
aussi on repasse à ma droite musique
c'est l'une des meilleurs coachs en
ile-de-france de pole dance
elle est coupable d'être à la fois
ravissante et d'être brillante
fructueuse dans les débats sportifs
notre ambassadrice de charme hélène de
la grange nous fait l'honneur de venir
une nouvelle fois sur cette émission
vous avez bien et même très bien très
bien vite revenir encore voilà vous êtes
devenu un petit peu titulaire dans cette
émission petites promotions j'aime bien
voilà maintenant vous êtes disponible à
toutes les émissions
on termine par le meilleur d'entre nous
musique on ne le présente plus il est
coupable d'être l'un des plus grands
présidents sportif que les yvelines est
connu à la manière d'un zidane partout
où il passe il engrange les succès le
président de l'étoile sportive de
trappes mustapha larfaoui est avec nous
pour cette émission ont ce soir
bonjour quand je tape fort vous
téléspectateurs
je pense que je vais partir d'ailleurs
vous allez partir mais parce que c'est
le meilleur moment de l'émission c'est
ce que je préfère des émissions alors
voir alors dans cette émission on parle
quand même de vous ne quittez pas le
plateau et après on parlera notamment du
coût de vous voilà on n'en dit pas plus
pour les pour les téléspectateurs pour
l'instant voilà enfin on provoque des
tuners une quinzaine de minutes à peu
près 2 ap pas troisième thème
alors avant de vous présenter les thèmes
de l'émission j'aimerais qu'on parle du
trophée des entreprises qui s'est
déroulée le jeudi 1er juin le concept 5
140 compétiteurs ont été répartis par
équipes de 3 est comme son nom l'indiqué
la compétition concerne les entreprises
ces dernières étaient essentiellement
issus du département des yvelines comme
tous les ans le trophée s'est déroulé à
travers l'île de loisirs petite
particularité cette année les
participants se sont élancés du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
au programme 1 5 km de course à pied une
course d'orientation de 2 5 km une
épreuve de radeaux et du vtt on écoute
les participants c'est la société on
n'est pas tout seul
si si c'est vraiment de la solidarité et
par rapport au travail aussi ça
contribue à former des liens dans des
moments atroces rapprocher de certaines
sociétés qui perd connaissance et des
liens et pourquoi pas à l'avenir
collaboré ont séquencé là les conseils à
mes tiens tu as fait la grande
entreprise mais aussi voilà qu'on
s'attaque aux stands alors que pensez
vous de cette compétition sportive qui
réunit les entreprises raul quel est
votre avis sur cette compétition on
avait déjà parlé des manifestations
sportives qui se qui se multipliaient y
compris dans les yvelines pour peu
importe les raisons soit pour des choses
caritative où je pense que c'est très
très bien toutes les toutes les toutes
les occasions de s'illustrer à travers
le sport sont très bien solliciter les
gens à se bouger figurer à travers le
sport c'est une très bonne chose
c'est une bonne manière de se
représenter donc voilà là c'est les
entreprises
peut-être une fois c'est pour une autre
une oeuvre et c'est donc c'est une bonne
chose hélène ça crée forcément des liens
de faire une compétition sportive comme
ça en pleine nature
oui de toute façon je pense que dans une
entreprise crée forcément du lien ça
permet aussi de se retrouver d'une autre
façon d'un travail de tête rencontrer
d'autres entreprises dans des domaines
différents et dans les mêmes domaines
c
ça change un peu de la concurrence ou
des rapports habituels sac a forcément
dû lire est informé alors d'abord c'est
l'essence même du sport on crée du lien
donc vous mettez n'appartiennent
manifestations sportives en place c'est
par définition la gestion du lien après
pas par définition c'est du sport donc
c'est tout bénéfique pour pour la santé
la santé publique
et puis on parle de sport et
d'entreprises donc les deux ont des
valeurs également à transmettre
on transmet des valeurs dans le sport
qui sont celles qu'on retrouve dans
l'entreprise ou qu'on devrait retrouver
dans l'entreprise et vice versa donc
voilà donc ça crée du lien c'est bon
pour la santé publique et en même temps
les valeurs sont importantes
yann quand on voit les épreuves opposé
il ya notamment du vélo est ce que ça
rapproche vraiment les gens le faire du
cyclisme le sac en pleine nature le
sillage des bars au vélodrome de 50 ans
domine
si vous n'êtes pas fan non pas du tout
s'il pouvait faire
le départ un petit peu plus loin et puis
nous permettre de pouvoir nous entraîner
plus régulièrement ça m'irait bien
marqué par cet article
après non moi je suis fan du sport à
l'entreprise pour pour une simple et
bonne raison c'est que derrière
l'entreprise c'est le moment dans la
journée où on passe le plus de temps et
c'est vrai que peut-être de pouvoir si
une entreprise permet et les emplois
permettre de pouvoir inclure une phase
de sport à l'intérieur de la delà de la
journée
je pense que derrière il ya une
productivité il ya une ambiance dans le
travail qui est complètement
complètement différente
et ouais et ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut développer et qui est
normal malheureusement c'est pas
possible dans tous les domaines mais dès
que c'est possible c'est vrai que je
pense que les gens qui ont là
les filles ont accès on ouvrait une
véritable chance et ça il faut pouvoir
le mesurer il faut que tu puisses le
mesure est vrai à oui c'était la dixième
édition vous votez pour une 11ème
édition faut que ça bienvenue c'est
cette compétition pour l'emploi du vélo
par part du vélodrome j'espère que le
vélo donc vous entend et yann on regarde
une participants j'ai cru 1 140
participants mais j'ai cru demandé que
c'était un mode de sélection des futurs
candidats aux élections législatives
pour remplir l'assemblée nationale et
probablement au rendement sortir des
craintes d'un ça peut être aussi long
boyau alors posera la question pourquoi
pas alors votre valeur alors on va
passer maintenant pour eve de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous en parler de la saison
2 et des handballeuses de montigny le
bretonneux
nous reviendrons également sur le départ
de mustapha larbaoui du club de football
de trappes mustapha on leur parle un
petit peu plus tard mais avant de
développer ces thèmes coup de projecteur
sur la première victoire de tony yoka
chez les professionnels
tout le monde l'attendait au tournant il
a réussi ses débuts pour cette grande
première chez les professionnels le
champion olympique français à tony hawk
a terrassé par ko au deuxième round
l'américain travis clark pourtant
invaincu jusqu'à présent au palais des
sports à paris
lucide l'illinois originaires de
chanteloup les vignes ne s'est pas
enflammé après son combat au palais des
sports donc on l'écouté il était au
micro de nos confrères de sci
d'observation j'avais conclu pour que
c'est comment il voulait la jouer avec
moi
[Musique]
on s'était trompé à la godille
son appel de l'équipe munchi's est mort
merci
nous
[Musique]
la question sur ce thème tony yoka est
il déjà un grand boxeur
à 25 ans il est champion olympique qui
remporte facilement son premier combat
professionnel
est-ce que c'est déjà un grand boxeur
vous votez oui ou non il est grand des
jardins de mètres 0-2 il est grand vous
êtes partagés yann complètement pas
faire un petit duel avec mustapha allez
pour vous re trouvailles
mustapha vous comment on est d'accord
dans les îles oui mais non oui ce n'est
pas juste a pas le petit duel avant
d'aller déjà un grand boxeur oui moi je
le disais il mesure j'ai vu je fais de
plus de m il fait 2 mai qui doit et 109
kg et grands il est grand par la taille
ouais je pense qu'il est il il en impose
déjà il a il a un style absolument qui
lui est propre et par définition il est
déjà dans
dans la qualité des grands champions et
je serais curieux de savoir ce que va
donner l'enfant puisqu'on en parle aussi
je crois que madame est également
championne de bain mais voilà il est
déjà il s'inscrit déjà dans la méthode
dans le style dans la façon dont il se
présente il a son tempérament alors bien
évidemment c'est à vérifier
c'est à consolider comme on dit mais je
trouve qu'il a déjà les qualités de ce
contre les cas de ce qu'on attendrait
d'un grand champion alors oui oui oui
parce que là il l'aide et les champions
olympiques il avait vraiment préparé son
affaire et un effet il a vraiment dominé
son son domaine donc il fait partie des
grands boxeurs puisque en plus il boxe
dans la catégorie reine
maintenant et il à la question comme l'a
répété à ce qu'on peut déjà grand c'est
déjà être embauchés ardres que désormais
question parce que c'est ma dernière vu
au vu du au vu d'une vue du combat et de
l'adversaire qui lui a été présenté lors
de ce premier combat jeu
voilà je doute à part dans l'aspect
phase de préparation billing boss
j'ai l'impression que j'ai l'impression
je suis plus affûté que lui aujourd'hui
que l'adversaire qu'il a eue qu'il a pu
avoir
si j'irai pas digéré d'avoir suggéré par
le combattre mais voilà moi ou je fais
et je n'ai pas l'impression
cet adversaire était prêt à faire à
venir défendre à venir défendre ou à
venir se battre contre un
un contre un challenger voilà c'est
juste le contenu qui fait que je trouve
ça un petit peu dommage maintenant il a
pris en expérience et à dire dans la
phase de préparation d'un championnat
dans la ilaha illa appris de ce faux pas
de ces championnats mais de de ce combat
chez les professionnels il a appris un
petit peu et il faut y aller étape par
étape
c'était moi ce que j'aime premier
constat les voilà bien sûr bien sûr donc
qu'il a il a appris dans toute cette
démarche aujourd'hui jusqu'au j'apprécie
c'est qu'il ya son os dif est à 4 ans
donc ça lui laisse quand même le temps
justement de s'aguerrir et le prochain
combat à lyon en octobre
je pense qu'il aurait même pu y avoir
lieu dans quinze jours mais pour valider
quand même ce que je ce que je disais il
a mis ko au deuxième à la limite ça
aurait été laborieux mais non il ya eu
un round d'observation
il a porté l'estocade donc c'est en ça
ou je dis qu'à un moment donné ça aurait
été laborieux et novatrice si ce n'est
que pour la neige s'était pas tout à
fait la différence avec gravel à nos
quatre grandes différences au niveau par
définition de la taille mais franchement
il est parti puis en plus ils ne portent
bien you can't you car ça fait quatre
bons on a dû lui faire souvent ça de là
mais je pense en tous les cas bien parti
c'est ce qu'on lui souhaite de mettre
tout le monde
chaillot raul vous qu est le spécialiste
boxe sur ce plateau est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec kia loup est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec mustapha je pense
qu'il a il a encore des preuves à
fournir maintenant il a il est dans le
schéma classique de ceux qui ont une
chance de rappeler les dernières années
de deux belles les belles dernières
années de boxe française en un poids
lourd de mormeck et c'est parce que
d'abord physiquement il fait un peu
penser à aux poids lourds qui domine la
catégorie maintenant comme les anthony
josue wilders qui sont des fêtes des
poids lourds mais extrêmement sec
donc c'est un peu c'est ce genre de
boxeur qui prédomine ensuite
il est champion olympique et c'est ce
qui lui a permis de s'américaniser
combien donner les moyens d'aller
s'entraîner aux états unis il sentait
sapin orné maintenant et ça paraît
maintenant indispensable pour espérer
d'eux pour espérer faire partie des
meilleurs mondiaux parce qu'il ya
vraiment une école et surtout chez les
poids lourds une vraie école de la boxe
aux états unis et c'est un passage
obligatoire il est passé chez les
cubains pour préparer pour toutes sa
phase de préparation olympique en
amateur là il suit le cursus classique
du futur champion du monde
après la catégorie elle est devenue
ultra relevé c'est intelligent de dire
que qu'il faudra quatre ans pour parce
qu' on pourrait vite se projeter sur sur
six mois un an
là le combat il était manille alors de
toute façon pour un premier combat
professionnel c'était l'adversaire qui
convenait mais on s'attendait à ce
résultat là aussi mille îles à montrer
quand même qu'il avait une box un très
bon niveau international en bonne
professionnelle
oui justement il ya l'idée que peut-être
l'adversaire était trop facile
finalement est-ce que ça a été une belle
rameurs d'un peu de sa saveur à cette
victoire
non mais c'est un problème c'est que je
pense que ce combat il était trop
attendu par rapport à ce qu'ils
représentent et c'est pour ça qu'il est
restée très froide tony hawk and on en a
fait tout un spectacle parce que c'est
tony hawk à qui les champions olympiques
et que maintenant toute la france est
derrière lui mais en fait pour lui c'est
ce combat là c'est un début
c'était pas un ce n'était pas un combat
bankable posté par c'est le c'est une
mise en bouche sur contre moi le
personnage ce qu'il peut dégager sa
façon d'aller super qui sont super
humble il et voilà il je pense que celui
avère bien sa communication ceux qui
gagnent voilà je suis la dernière nuit
tout d'abord un grand voile à devenir
très bien géré il ça va être
et ça et j'espère qu'une chose c'est que
sable qui puisse réaliser son objectif
dans trois donc adresse a quant lui
parce que parce que derrière il va y
avoir une vraie
une vraie ferveur une verrée ferveur qui
va l'accompagner seul bémol s'il arrive
dans une période où la catégorie a
jamais été aussi relevée c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'en ce moment sur les
poids lourds où il ya des ovnis et est
ce que les jeunes mais bon on te dit je
suis allée pas forcément plus lui qui
n'a pas de 7 ans 6 matchs et voilà est
donc bon est ce que ce serait rendre à
l'espoir que plus grande et elle le fait
d'être ou d'avoir combattu avec un
engouement comme comme celui-là d'avoir
remporté cette victoire au 2e round
est-ce qu'il doit miser là dessus il
repose la même chose sur le prochain
combat le combat d'après pour créer une
espèce d'émulation tour de l'huile se
dire finalement je voir tony yoka pour
de ron je veux pas les louper comme mike
tyson à l'époque faisait une res vegas
ou autre je pense que chaque combat est
très différents comme des garçons disent
et c'est un premier c'est voilà il est
challenger il a envie d'y aller ça va on
saura vraiment si les grands comme tu
dis et s'il a vraiment du dd capacité
s'il se maintient et s'y sent très bien
que s'ils continuent à
avoir des victoires pas forcément chaos
en deux rounds comme c'était le cas mais
des beaux combats voilà et ça ça se on
le verra que avec d'autres adversaires
et sur le long terme en fait pour avoir
un beau champion il faut aussi un beau
un bel adversaire un beau match de foot
c'est quand arrive est très positif
voilà arrivés à l'arrivée les duels et
duel prost senna s'était enfin voilà les
champions sont restés dans l'histoire de
leur foi de champion mais bien sûr et
bien sûr s'il ya un dominateur
c'est quand même beaucoup plus difficile
et il faut marquer d'autant plus les
esprits pour pouvoir pour pouvoir rpt
est fou s'il faut rester fort et 7 ans
d'histoire qu'il fasse envie aussi
pour l'instant c'est assez
impressionnant les jeux olympiques est
ce que ça représente pour le commun des
mortels est ce que ça représente dans la
boxe c'est très c'est un film quoi donc
pour la jusqu'à présent personne ne
courait après tony hawk a maintenant ça
va quand même coûté un peu d'argent de
monter sur l'île contre lui donc ça va
que les années volées vrais adversaires
vont arriver est-ce qu'il faut qu'il
dépasse également mustapha le cadre de
la boxe vous en parliez tout à l'heure
voilà il ya un aspect mode histoire
d'amour avec la boxeuse estelle mossely
ils vont avoir un bébé
vous disiez tout à l'heure à ce qu il
faut qu il dépasse aussi ce cadre-là de
la boxe créer une histoire peut-être
une storytelling hausse de lui comme ont
pu le faire les grands je pense
notamment à mohamed ali qui avait refusé
de partir à combattre
où vladimir klitscho qui est pareil a
soutenu le conflit en ukraine
est-ce qu'il doit dépasser peut-être ce
cadre de la boxe pour créer une histoire
de lui si je devais le conseiller ce
serait justement de ne rien raconter du
tout il se maintenir dans son sport et
de faire exactement ce qu'il sait faire
si on commence à faire du marketing dans
la boxe c'est à dire je veux être marque
était comme les joues comme le boxeur
qui tape toujours au deuxième pour qu'on
vienne me voir si je tape bien au
deuxième si je commence à marquer tu es
comme étant celui qui donne le plus de
suspense et je meurs à la fin je tue à
la fin on est dans des histoires qu'on
se raconte c'est pas ça le sport c'est
pas ça la boxe donc moi je pense qu'il a
il a tout d'un champion justement parce
qu'il a cette humilité à chaque fois de
combattre avec l'idée que de la belle
idée qui se fait de son sport et de ses
adversaires aussi bien de monde amateur
que dans le monde professionnel
aujourd'hui mais de toute façon mais ça
peut le permettre est connue du grand
racontera des histoires à sa place lui
doit rester absolument rivés sur son
sport sur son sur son être en gros qui
reste tony yoka dans le bon sens il en
écrira des histoires sa place et tous
les grands ont été mitigés parce que
après ça les dépasse tous les grands
joueurs de football sont dépassés par
leur part le sport ça qu'on on les amène
dans d'autres disciplines
quand ils sont grands justement dans
qu'il a tout d'un grand c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et pour le reste
ça suivra
et c'est ça qui va être compliqué à
gérer n'oublions jamais qu'il s'attaque
quand même à ddd catégorie à du lourd
il peut y avoir un accident un accident
de parcours mais j'entends un accident
physique physiologique
il peut avoir plein de choses dans sa
vie personnelle vie sentimentale le
pognon va rentrer en jeu il ya plein de
choses qui font que
il est temps de venir c'est très
compliqué d'être champion dans tous les
sports parce qu'il ya tous ces
ingrédients à bien et pour moi le seul
conseil que j'aurais à lui donner si je
devais lui en donner un c'est de rester
concentré sur son objectif d'être le
meilleur point bas le reste on l'écrira
avec lui probablement même sans lui il
peut être au niveau des mohamed ali des
grands qui ont marqué la boxe sur la
route est très très longue mais il part
avec qui part avec tous les tous les
avantages et pour le faire maintenant ça
dépend de lui ça dépend effectivement il
faut pas qu'il faut surtout pas qu'il
soit
parasite est pour l'instant par
justement tous ces facteurs que vous
mentionniez parce que c'est c'est
tellement dur la boxe c'est le haut
niveau
tellement obligé le haut niveau dans
tous les sports bien sûr donc il
il a fourni des preuves mais comment
vous dire qu'elle soit encore par
rapport aux autres très petit possible
même si je lui enlève rien à tout le
potentiel qui qu'il a aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est un potentiel c'est ce
que tu sais rien il faut il faut il faut
aller chercher les conventions mais il
peut le faire mais à l'ôter également la
bonne performance d'un autre boxeur
yvelinois pendant cette soirée à paris
ahmed el moussaoui le verrier roy s'est
imposé contre le russe froman c'est
l'hiver stuff je ne sais pas si je pense
bien au point
il affiche désormais un bilan de 26
victoires dont 6 par ko pour trois
défaites dans sa carrière une réaction
raul sur ahmed el moussaoui qui embauche
un nouveau combat finalement qu'on avait
pris un pari la dernière mission je suis
venu en vous disant qu'il y aurait trois
yvelinois champions l'union européenne
je pense au courant septembre octobre et
je le maintiens et je pense parce que
justement parce que je pense qu ahmed el
moussaoui soit elle sera le train de
transformer la team farruggia registre
avec les yankees croisé les gants avec
marvin quand il était quand il était
même pas d'eau laissant et
donc voilà je peux encore une belle
performance là après c'est vrai on voit
les les statistiques du ciel best-of
s'était pas non plus une montagne mais
voilà je pense que c'est une victoire de
plus
et je pense que il est vraiment c'est le
plus gros challenger pour le titre ubs
et je suis sûr qu'il va là qui va
remporter la ceinture
on lui souhaite en tout cas bon courage
on continue ses pages résultat par du
handball féminin la saison de nationale
2 ac terminer le samedi 3 juin pour
montigny-le-bretonneux les immortels ont
clôturé leur année par une défaite
contre noisy le grand à domicile le
score 30 à 26 au classement les
yvelinoises aux portes du podium avant
la rencontre termine finalement à la
cinquième place du classement
l'objectif fixé en début de saison en
écoute les réactions
les filles se sont se sont retrouvés ont
un urgent à dire à un esprit de groupe
ce soit sur le terrain voire même en
dehors du terrain et ça a payé quand je
suis vraiment très fier d'elle et on a
retrouvé
j'allais dire une âme et à une équipe à
montigny c'était une très très belle
saison qui a commencé
difficilement ça a été compliqué de
reconstruire le groupe de repartir avec
un nouvel entraîneur le temps prendre
tondent les bases c'est pas facile on a
eu un petit passage à vide au début et
on a su se remobiliser pour finir en
beauté on a tout explosé à fin de saison
les yvelinoises qui descendait de
national une avait surtout très mal
débuté leur saison elles ont perdu cinq
matchs sur scène jusqu'en novembre
elles se sont ensuite reprises pour
enchaîner en fin de saison six victoires
consécutives la question sur ce thème
ont-elles réussi leur saison oui ou non
oui pour mustapha oui pour tout le monde
évidemment je vous ai vus prendre
ensuite la raquette
alors pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est qu'on en a il parlait déjà lors
d'une émission autour de cette table au
moment où justement elle avait beaucoup
de défaite en début de championnat et on
a fait référence à la descente de l'an
dernier et on disait à cette table que
ce qui était important c'était la
manière dont vous allez reprendre en
main cette équipe est donc bah coup de
chapeau aux dirigeants en général à
toute cette équipe qui a su qui a su se
retransformer et maintenant ils sont
vraiment sur une dynamique de fin de
championnat qui laisse présager à mon
avis une belle saison pour les
prochaines et quand on reconstruit c'est
souvent beaucoup plus compliqué je crois
même qu ici on avait dit qu'ils étaient
descendus de nationale 1 en nationale 2
mais il était envisageable de continuer
de descendre souvent c'est c'est un peu
là l'image vous savez une larme l'arbre
qui s'effondre ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
plus de bruit que qu'une pelouse qui
poussent là en l'occurrence c'est en
preuve de fin de saison
c'est vrai je la sais moi les valides et
les valises et supporté voilà donc ma
crainte était qu'ils continuent à
descendre ils ont su freiner cette chute
ils ont su rebondir et donc pour moi
c'est extraordinairement bien réussi
voilà on aurait pu imaginer qu'il revend
qu'elle remonte à mai c'était pas
possible cette année mais la dynamique
est bonne hélène faut-il boire le verre
à moitié plein ou à moitié vide
voilà rares voire voire bain de toute
façon
toujours à moitié plein elle elle
descendait en national 1 elle passe en
nationale 2 il fallait au moins qu'elle
qu'elle se ressaisisse qu'elle arrive à
performer à reconstruire quelque chose à
l'onf est brillamment voilà en fin de
saison on les attend là les prochaines
juste une question
elles sont pas audités dans la saison à
sont dans le top 200 top 2 dans
l'acquisition prend que la deuxième
partie et sont dans le top 200
pour imaginer que le championnat soit
avons commencé en prennent les résultats
est ce que il n'ya pas des regrets à
avoir sur du coup cette première partie
de saison quand on voit le
la deuxième partie de saison qui est
extraordinaire on peut toujours se dire
finalement la montée elle pouvait être
accessible cette année non il y avait la
première phase qui était la
reconstruction de quand on tire le
parachute il faut voilà il faut il faut
le dire il faut digérer donc non c'est
pas c'est pas possible
par contre mais voilà là où je suis un
petit peu déçu c'est que l perdre le
dernier match à domicile contre noisy le
grand qui était aussi une équipe de
milieu de tableau et c'est dommage de
finir sur cette clique note négative
l'arbre de l'arbitré les a pas aidé les
dirigeants mais ça tu as encore de
l'enjeu un point de plus elle pouvait
terminer quatrièmes à quatre c'est c'est
un peu le belge a gagné voilà quand on
demande si le l'objectif de la saison
est réussi ou pas c'était l'objectif
était de se maintenir en nationale 2
qu'elles finissent à la nuit' 9e place
ou à la 5e place à son résultat est le
même donc voilà résultat complètement
complètement
complètement atteints et deuxième chose
voilà il faut vraiment
se nourrir de cette dynamique de six
sept matchs consécutifs de remporter
leur deuxième partie de saison pour
reconstruire sur sur la suite mais là
sacrifier une saison selon vous les
raisons et les objectifs du club il ya
bondi en fin est à dire et c'est stop
alors que ben elle il était parti sur
une très très mauvaise dit voilà une
très très mauvaise dynamique avec avec
cinq ou six victoires cinq ou six
défaites dès le début de saison
donc voilà non là c'est vraiment très
très très très bien et bon courage pour
la suite
maintenant moi je pense que
l'année prochaine fois peut-être pas
viser la montée faut peut-être viser
simplement gamme salambo consolider les
fondations pour voir qu'on est encore
capable d'aller un poil plus haut dans
cette danse est dans cette poule pour
assurer une remontée qu'israël elle
certaines parce que si c'est pour
rentrer dans une dans une dynamique de
yoyo c'est vraiment difficile à gérer
quoi raul vous êtes d'accord avec yann
il faut pas aller trop vite non plus non
non surtout effectivement il ya eu un
dernier match ce qui qui montre que ça
me manque encore un petit peu de
solidité même si effectivement on
remarque que les restructurations et la
nouvelle stratégie a payé parce que ça a
répondu et eu du répondant au niveau des
résultats
quand on voit qu'il ya une défaite à
domicile avec un petit club à la fin
peut-être qu'effectivement se mobilisent
et enfin ceux se consolider et puis
faire une bonne perf dans la catégorie
en dessous points je pensais plus
intelligent on va maintenant à quitter
notre page résultats pour passer à notre
coup de projecteur
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans notre coup de
projecteur nous allons parler de
football et d'un homme qui sur ce
plateau l'emblématique mustapha larbaoui
l'homme qui a passé 14 années à la tête
du club de l'étoile sportive de trappes
a annoncé le 29 mai dernier
mustapha qu'est-ce que vous avez annoncé
le 29 mai dernier je donc j'annonce que
je quitte l'étoile sportive de trappes
la présidente de l'étoile sportive 1
puis quitte pas le club je vais rester
bien évidemment adhérents et sierra si
on veut bien de moi encore président
d'honneur mais j'arrête mes fonctions de
président on va dire opérationnelle du
club de foot de train pas alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer un petit
peu les raisons du coup qui m'ont vous
ont poussé à briguer partir de ce club
où vous étiez depuis 14 ans brisard de
votre vie voilà en quelques mots c'est
ça
14 ans je trouve que c'est c'est
beaucoup c'est à la fois
beaucoup de saison beaucoup de résultats
beaucoup d'engagement et j'ai toujours
eu cette idée selon laquelle les gens ne
devaient pas s'accrocher à leur poste
voire même se dire que on a pu
construire pendant un certain temps et
qu'on pourrait profiter du temps qui
reste pour en récolter les fruits moi je
sais pas ce que c'est que cette
expression c'est les enfants qui doivent
en récolter les fruits
c'est la ville c'est le club c'est
surtout pas moi c'est surtout pas le
président moi j'ai fait ce que j'avais à
faire il y avait des choses à construire
il ya des choses à bâtir c'était assez
assez compliqué au départ il ya 14 ans
voilà il ya de belles choses qui ont été
réalisés et il en reste toujours à faire
donc je pense qu'il est temps de passer
la main 56 ans je suis arrivé j'en avais
40 fait le calcul 42 merci voilà donc je
pense qu'il faut passer la main à
quelqu'un à peu près de renaître cet
âge-là connais ton successeur alors je
moi je les jeux les jeux les choisit on
va dire je vais choisi parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé à mes côtés
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur un aspect
important pour moi c'est tout ce qui est
notion de prévention prévention
par le sport donc c'est quand même mon
leitmotiv ça a été le football prétexte
à l'éducatif
allez allez change de valeur voilà tout
c'est toutes ces notions là donc je les
choisis mais y aura un vote
donc c'est une association c'est plus de
1000 adhérents donc il ya beaucoup de
monde ce seront les donc les adhérents
du club qui voteront moi j'ai fait le
choix d'adèle razak guessoum qui était
pendant deux ans le référent prévention
médiation
on se connaît depuis maintenant une
dizaine d'années j'ai fait ce choix
parce que je sais que ça sera le choix
de la continuité ça sera le choix de de
quelqu'un qui appréciait le travail qui
a envie de le défendre à temps il y aura
un vote
il y aura peut-être aussi des gens
d'autres candidats je sais pas c'est par
lettre recommandée qu'on saura puisque
les statuts prévoient que les
candidatures arrive 15 jours
avant le vote donc ça sera jusqu'à
samedi mais moi j'ai fait le choix d'un
homme parce que danone aurait pu être
une femme pour le coup mais d'un homme
parce qu'on a beaucoup travaillé
ensemble
voilà mais ses 14 ans ces 24 24 7 7
en tous les cas c'est comme ça que le
conçoit je voulais tout courant de tout
parce que c'est quand même il ya un gros
nationale qui est créé dans un club
voilà je disais toujours le moindre
ongles cassés d'un des enfants j'ai
besoin de savoir ce que j'ai besoin de
savoir l'état de santé des enfants que
la prise en charge ans mes parents
et donc voilà donc c'est vraiment au
quotidien extrêmement extrêmement
prenant c'est chronophage
voilà donc il faut savoir passer la main
est ce que vous comprenez ce choix
autour de la table enfin moi je vois je
vois qu'une chose c'est vrai que
le seul président qui a fait autant de
temps c'est uniquement quand même
c'était la boutade du jour jeudi
ce départ de mustapha ben oui comme il
le dit à un moment donné ou faut se
retirer et on peut pas il a donné quand
même 14 ans de sa vie mais quatorze ans
de son temps quatorze ans de passion
d'implication et je pense qu'à un moment
donné on a quand même eu le droit à des
vacances quoi et à avoir en tout cas
bâle us de trappes d'un autre d'un autre
poste que de celui là pas d'une autre
façon et profiter un peu de ce qui a été
dense et qui a été mis en place
tu vas sûrement plus dans leur version
bah moi je les enfants ce qu'est ce
qu'il voulait c'était d'être arrivé à la
catégorie u6 quand je suis avec quatorze
ans après la catégorie u20 ce qui fait
quasiment une génération une génération
foot par la génération mitterrand
génération larbaoui mais là et puis
surtout voilà moi je le dis mes parents
c'est important je me suis rendu compte
que je gaspille et pas mal de temps
aussi au détriment de ce qui m'est cher
aussi donc mes parents et là maintenant
j'ai vraiment fait le choix de consacrer
et puis et puis elle est enfin il les
pharmacies enfin ya pas mal de choses
encore tu es tu es tu as des enfants qui
ont
des enfants tu as des enfants qui ont
commencé en russie c'est qui aujourd'hui
sont les vins dans l'équipe une
donc quand on parle ici on en a souvent
parlé du rôle du président du rôle des
dirigeants tout à l'heure yan tu disais
il faut il faudrait pas qu'ils se
précipitent sur la montée mais qu'il
faut consolider le rôle d'un président
c'est qu'à un moment donné
le compétiteur nulle envie de monte
monte monte et le président a un rôle
sur le long terme on parle du quotidien
qui est prenant mais il y aussi cette
vision stratégique à long terme qui font
qu'il faut maintenir justement la
question sur ce thème tout le monde
peut-il être président club est-ce que
tout petit peut être présidents de clubs
pour voter oui aux influences des
fusions président non non raul pourquoi
je pense que il ya il ya un nombre de
sacrifices à être prêts à faire il faut
je pense que il faut avoir un mode de
vie qui le permet c'est que c'est pas
donné à tout le monde
il faut des capacités intellectuelles
déjà première pédagogique et nos minimes
g
j'ai une faim j'ai eu une vie avant
métier que je fais aujourd'hui et mon
nom mon patron à l'époque me disait et
anne vous êtes chef c'est vous qui êtes
là pour pour donner les directives ne
sont pas là pour réfléchir ils sont là
pour faire ce que vous leur dites faire
donc tout le monde n'est pas équipé pour
pouvoir être président d'un club pour
pouvoir être dirigeant d'une société
être chef d'un groupe être être dans une
équipe de foot il ya logiquement un
capitaine de tous les joueurs ne sont
pas faits pour un capitaine donc les
chats que chaque personne a son rôle et
donc dans président d'un club
et puis après il faut avoir aussi une
envie de
deux lettres et
j'ai eu des sollicitations mais des
invitations à m'impliquer dans la vie de
la fédération française de cyclisme et
moi aujourd'hui j'en ai pas du tout en
quoi c'est enfin voilà peut-être plus
tard mais aujourd'hui on est prêt à
s'oublier
même en tant que porte il faut s'oublier
je pense être prêt à raccrocher quand on
fait 50 ans qu'on s'est trop chronophage
peut-être mais oui mais à la fois pour
sa vie personnelle pour sa vie sportive
comme tu disais et puis il faut avoir
non seulement vis mais faut se donner
les objectifs et tenir la distance sur
une assez longue durée aussi parce qu'on
n'est pas on n'essaie pas d'être
président pendant deux trois ans je
pense que toi tu as quand même fait 14
ans tu imagines tu as pu créer faire des
essais et cetera sur peut-être des
décisions et au final voit ce qui marche
et le voir ce qui marchait mieux faut
savoir aussi prendre des décisions qui
sont pas forcément celles que
comprendrait pour nous mais plus pour
voilà tous les clubs est un groupe il
faut les prendre la position du décision
aussi parce que combien de fois vous
voyez des gens qui je vais à droite ou
jouer à gauche et ils sont incapables de
dire est là et bien quand vous êtes le
président vous avez beau avoir une
interminable
il faut être capable de trancher parfois
et de dire de quoi les gens qui décident
pas maintenant chacun à manger bien fait
comme je dénonce et j'ai pas dit j'ai
pas touché avec ça mais
il ya des jouets est capable de prendre
une décision et de la fumée et de la
fumée et de et d'en assumer les
conséquences les actes et les résultats
derrière
d'après la définition ian le président
doit veiller au bon fonctionnement
sur le plan matériel financier et moral
du club vous êtes d'accord m'a bien sûr
que c'est ta définition
bah oui matériel financier et moral
oui bien sûr ça fait partie des deux de
certains axes que je pense que je pense
que mustapha pour nous dire qu'il a
d'autres alors mon staff
en tous les cas c'est sûr la notion de
fonctionnement sur lequel je pourrais je
pourrais insisté c'est à dire que l'idée
que se doit il doit participer au bon
fonctionnement
ça laisse à penser que c'est un truc qui
tourne huilé avec des engrenages contre
le fonctionnement mais il suffit de
mettre un peu d'huile ici un peu là en
fait c'est plus que le fonctionnement
c'est
la vision quasi philosophique qu'on a de
l'objet donc l'objet en l'occurrence
club de foot mais ça peut être ça peut
être d'autres sports c'est la vision
qu'on a du sport et la vision qu'on a
des êtres qui traverse qui traverse le
club qui traverse ce sport pourquoi on
le fait en l'occurrence est donc cette
vision qu'elle est philosophique et
stratégiques
c'est ça à mon avis qui est important
pour le reste pour le bon fonctionnement
je rappelle quand même que aujourd'hui
on parle de moi c'est juste que c'est
quasiment une cinquantaine d'éducateurs
qui ont fait ce club pendant 14 ans et
c'est à eux que je que je rends hommage
sa part est une politesse que de dire on
les remercie d'un an c'est vrai c'est
eux qui ont fait ce quotidien dont on
parle ce fonctionnement dont on parle le
président
la présidente doit vraiment avoir à
coeur de 2,2 de s'inscrire dans la durée
dans le temps on disait dans deux trois
ans et c'est tout le monde est capable
d'être président pour répondre à la
question tout le monde est capable
le souci c'est de savoir est-ce que ça
dure or ça doit durer donc combien de
temps et pour quoi faire
mais sinon tout le monde peut le faire
il suffit d'être un élu de se présenter
simplement pour quoi faire
moi ce qui me paraît important c'est
cette notion d'objet on a un objet entre
les mains et cet objet là on prend à un
moment tu es dans un espace et on doit
la mener par ailleurs
avec voilà avec des objectifs qui ont
été établies et si possible qu'on va
atteindre la puissance assure les
éducateurs
mon fils à mon grand désarroi fait du
foot depuis 20 ans et aujourd'hui moi le
seul référent que j'ai dans le club de
foot de mon fils c'est le responsable de
l'école de foot de palaiseau je ne
connais pas le président je ne connais
pas d'autres personnes au sein de ce
club est donc cet éducateur c'est lui
qui transmet soit les messages que le
président a pu a pu lui a pu le faire
passer et c'est lui qui dégage l'image
du club de palaiseau à mes yeux est
aujourd'hui de ce que je vois je trouve
que c'est très très bien et donc en
effet comme tu dis il y a une vraie
responsabilité auprès des éducateurs et
donc le choix de ses éducateurs est
aussi important de la part d'un départ
d'un président est ce que tu dit tout à
l'heure de en off mais pas par rapport à
ton poste mais le fait de savoir
déléguer est très important aussi quand
on est quand on est un poste à
responsabilités farceur c'est un chef
d'entreprise chez l'entreprise sauf que
l'objet n'est pas le même il n'est pas à
but financier il est à but sportif donc
il peut être culturel mais ça reste à
challes entreprises s'arrête un chef
d'orchestre ça reste quelqu'un qui porte
une parole une vision une stratégie qui
fait classe il fait des choix et
pascal mais on va devoir refermer cette
page vous ce tapage avril la police pour
ses 14 ans à la tête du club de trappes
alors on passait maintenant notre focus
du jour il concerne les sports extrêmes
à tout juste 18 ans luca di meglio est
l'un des plus grands espoirs français de
la trottinette l'an dernier il a fini
deuxième du monster scooter conteste en
suisse l'équivalent des championnats
d'europe de la discipline y voyagent
dans toute l'europe pour disputer les
compétitions mais pourquoi s'est-il
lancé dans ce sport on écoute le prodige
au micro de tv fil 78
mon voisin il s'est acheté une
trottinette en fait et en achetant sa
trottinette genre je me suis dit j'ai un
défi je me suis dit ça à l'air pas mal
j'ai quand même essayé je me suis dit
mon père il m'a acheté une petite
routine est à un magasin qui s'appelle
cardy c'était une trottinette cliente
j'ai commencé à essayer
j'ai commencé à essaimer petit mais
première figure devant chez moi sur mon
tir au point genre j'ai bien kiffé et du
coup voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai
atterri dans là j'ai atterri dans la
matinée à yann une petite fraction sur
ce petit prodige de la trottinette
réactions en jeu j'aimerais juste
pouvoir enfin j'aimerais juste donc
j'aimerais vraiment le rencontrer parce
que celui qu'il a 18 ans je pense que
c'est un rendez vous j'ai discuté avec
lui pour savoir quels sont les axes de
travail qu'elles sont parce que arriver
à ce niveau là dans n'importe quelle
discipline il ya de la préparation il
est d'entraînement il ya du travail
donc j'aimerais savoir quels sont ces
axes de
wes styles de travail pour pouvoir
progresser maintenant c'est son choix
s'est hissée clac avec ça et bien tant
mieux
en effet là quand on voit les quand on
voit les images ça reste ça reste
spectaculaire
ben tant mieux pour lui il s'éclate
voilà rien n'a rien rien à ajouter mais
je pense que les changes peut être peut
être intéressant avec eux avec ce genre
de personne et et il doit avoir des
qualités physiques
divers et variés qui lui aurait
peut-être amené à d'autres résultats
dans des sports plus connu est plus plus
médiatisé alors après ses performances
le jeune luca attirer le regard des
annonceurs il a plusieurs sponsors dont
une marque de vêtements australienne on
l'écouté à partir de septembre
normalement septembre en fin d'année en
année normale j'ai commencé à être payée
par mon père mon sponsor qui est adx
coûteux ring c'est une marque de
trottinettes qui a un qui en faible
production en ce moment on va dire ce
plateau là c'est un prototype qui doit
sortir depuis allez ça doit faire quatre
ans qui doit sortir
et là on voit enfin de sortir et on
attend de voir le sentir pour que je
puisse avoir ma paye on va dire par mon
sponsor la question sur ce thème peut-il
gagner sa vie en faisant de la
trottinette
oui ou non voter vous partagez mon staff
non raul pourquoi vous avez vu raison de
la raquette sans hésitation et moi c'est
les sports extrêmes c'est que j'en ai
malheureusement mon itinéraire sportif a
été différent donc j'en ai pas vous
pratiquez vraiment mais c'est quelque
chose que j'apprécie beaucoup déjà aux
visions et je sais vraiment plus qu'à
apprécier la performance sportive ce
soit mais pas que la trottinette le
skateboard aussi tous ces sports de
glisse et je suis autant certains sports
j'ai encore du mal à vraiment
le reconnaître leur place dans des
grands événements comme les jo ou tout
simplement dans le grand média alors que
je trouve que les sports extrêmes et
même le surf mériterait vraiment s'être
lassé d'être votée mais les élèves iso
iso ils ont les x games je dirais ils
ont leur propre l'angola et autres
jouaient leur propre rôle mais ouais
maintenant c'est par suffisance laquelle
gît au sol étant d'une en tous les cas
ne leur permet pas d'en vivre et c'est
dommage pour moi c'est pas possible
non mais mais c'est dommage que que bon
il ya ces sportifs là parce qu'en soit
la performance sportive
intrinsèquement elle et elle est tout
aussi impressionnante que que celle d'un
homme d'un d'un messi devant aveux
devant un but un but de foot ou pourquoi
donc le foot pro bon la prouesse relégua
beaucoup trop d'argent dans la
renaissance dans le domaine du sport non
mais je prends beaucoup trop d'argent
pour beaucoup trop d'argent dans le
domaine du sport maintenant ce que je
trouve dommage dommage j'avais perdu mon
idée mais c'est passé pas grâce à
revenir
non on ne peut pas vivre de ce pont peut
pas vivre de ce type de sport je vais y
voit la seleçao geof pas oublier que la
moitié des athlètes français sont au rmi
bien sûr non mais donc je veux dire ça
car ça parle d'elle même c'est la moitié
des représentants des athlètes qui sont
allés à rio sont au rsa
pas de réflexion la première le môme il
aime ça donc louis déjà qu'ils fassent
ça qu'il fasse que ça qui ne pense qu'à
ça après tout ça reste une passion donc
on commence dans une passion on en est
si l'idée c'est de se dire est ce que ma
passion va rapporter du fric ou pas je
pense pas que ça sur la question qui se
pose donc il continue d'une part et
d'autre part un moment donné c est ce
que tous les sports rapporte du pognon
dire que les pubs vont aller où c'est le
plus visible ou ses banquiers bachelet
entendu tout à l'heure où ces
télévisuelle bref justement la question
c'est la question que je pose cerqueux
il ya probablement télévisuel où il ya
un public
la télé c'est d'imagés et c'est l'image
est bonne et on gagnera si l'image n'est
pas super bonne il sera pas suivie aux
gens mais bien moi qui continue à aimer
et à faire sont aujourd'hui d'une
facilité de médias quand même grâce à
internet on arrive à avoir des
retransmissions de certaines épreuves
qui sont beaucoup plus attisé donc voilà
j'ai tout à fait tout à fait
mais est-ce que vous avez vu un jour une
compétition de trottinette sur internet
n'ont donc à partir de là c'est je pense
ce émergents il ya une fédération avec
william scheller émergents
non mais ça fait longtemps qu'on en fait
de la trottinette dans la rue d'accord
ça fait déjà rire pendant ces la
poussière on envoie des trottinettes
mois les premières trottinette de
stricte que j'ai que j'ai pu voir c'est
à l'époque je faisais du roller puisque
ce sont des des sports de glisse et moi
je faisais du roller de vitesse donc pas
de pas de
pas de figure n'est rien mais durant nos
fidèles et donc je parle de ça ça fait
déjà plus d'une dizaine d'années
ça fait donc si ça avait dû percer un
moment ou un autre ce serait déjà une
bonne note envoyée à des sons que
l'évolution de ce gamin ça sera vers un
autre sport extrême que commence par là
en moyenne rider je parle à rider c'est
à dire quelqu'un qui peut faire du
skateboard tu peux faire qui peut faire
du surf rider peut toucher à 1500 euros
par mois en moyenne
avec ce que l'on appelle les prize money
c'est c'est à dire les gains qu'on
touche sont en fonction à la défense
qu'on fait pendant une compétition mais
500 euros finalement la moyenne c'est
rien du tout et bien non c'est vrai
c'est compliqué surtout que une carrière
c'est entre 15 et 30 ans ils dépendent
les sports le surf on pouvait peut-être
un peu plus loin
oui et puis je pense que de toute façon
il faut quand même hein
un super niveau pour pouvoir déjà espéré
voilà toucher une somme lui le seul le
seul skeeter quand on connaît tous voilà
thomas et le solo le sol roller med que
l'on connaît non c'est aux camélias ça
commence par henin est le seul roller
mène que l'on connaît dans les sports
extrêmes à connaissez pas pourtant les
français et ils sont donc moins viendra
pas de la tour eiffel taïg khris
d'accord alors tout cas dans le top 5
justement des riders les plus riches au
monde on retrouve tony hawk
voilà qui est loschetter qui avait gagné
on a bouffé en 2008 parce qu'il était
voilà très connu à l'époque 12 millions
d'euros
il ya selon borders weitz avec 9
millions d'euros ou encore kelly slater
qui gagne chaque année entre 3 et 5
millions d'euros paris pourquoi ce qu'on
me connaît sait pas ce que c'est un surf
oxbow il est resté pendant des années
donc ça possible mais oui bien sûr mais
il ya toujours une escalade dans la
performance
suit les planches c'est parce qu'elles
ont été vendus et il fallait donc s'il
ya un marché
bah ça venait de visiter notre site est
classé et elle peut être au niveau
loisir peut-être voilà enfin
probablement tout simplement et donc
l'industrie peut s'y intéresser et si
risqué qui doute assez tard en plus il a
eu toute l'intelligence marketing voilà
je veux dire quiksilver aujourd'hui
c'est énorme
dans le classement des sportifs les
mieux payés au monde
il y a des sports extrêmes et des sports
automobiles il ya notamment voilà les
sports motorisés comme la formule 1 où
la moto gp qui sont des sports extrêmes
on peut le dire dans un autre domaine
mais motorisés là là là on voit lewis
hamilton voilà qui a par exemple 4
millions d'euros voilà
là il ya un recul est vrai qu'il ne faut
plus qu'on vende beaucoup de
trottinettes autant qu'on vende bagnols
chez mercedes chez bm mais c'est vrai
que c'est lié à sa saignée à une
industrie il ya des ventes au bout et
cellier de la visibilité
un sport un sport extrême que j'adore
c'est le belge jeunes ne le base jump
c'est à dire vous partez bien sûr un
point x ou y
les mecs sont point bas et il arrive
c'est plutôt sauter de la bio de la
tombe par la sonde une tour et les wings
et des de certains pensent de cette voie
là mais bon mais attention ça c'est de
plus en plus en vogue mais il était
arrivé en vie parce qu'ils ont fait de
plus en plus dans l'exceptionnel et ben
ghachir donc dans la performance des
chiens pour ce sont les esprits extrêmes
ils vont évoluer et j'en suis j surfer
les surfeurs font des choses avec la
neige maintenant et ils y passent des
idoles ride de plus autant que dans la
poudreuse comme pouvait le faire avant
il explore des spots et ils ont des
démons ils font des montages c'est juste
énorme
mais la technologie le plus extrême ça
pourrait être notre astronautes toi
parce que tu m'avais sied donc à un
moment donné il a aussi vendu un jeu
très brève et des images je préfère
comme ça ça commence sur ce thème
lagache j'ai mis la cloche s'est
vraiment passé à notre rubrique débats
dans cette émission un jingle
dans notre rubrique débats nous allons
parler d'actions caritatives 18900 euros
c'est la somme récoltée par
l'association sos gazelles à l'occasion
de la 25e édition du tiebreak formé au
total plus d'une cinquantaine de
sportifs et anciens gloires du monde du
sport ont répondu présentes au golf de
bêtement à poissy parmi eux sonny
anderson nicolas douchez antoine
kombouaré et philippe candeloro
l'ancien tennisman yannick noah revient
aussi régulièrement participé à
l'événement au programme des défis
sportifs et une vente aux enchères avec
de prestigieux lots comme le maillot du
prodige killian mba paix ou encore de
marco vers ati cela a permis de récolter
donc des fonds pour financer deux
projets celui de l'accompagnement de
jeunes talents franciliens et la
finalisation d'un centre polyvalent au
sénégal la question sur ce thème les
sportifs ont-ils le droit le devoir
pardon de participer à des oeuvres
caritatives
les sportifs ont-ils le devoir de
participer à des oeuvres caritatives
devoir assister là dessus je vois raoul
walsh divers ouais moi j'ai envie de toi
je pense qu'on ait nos sponsors c'est la
notion de devoir car voilà un constat
pour son jubilé à lewis n'a pas enfin
non non non il n'y a pas de devoirs à
participer à quoi que ce soit
ils ont un devoir de parties de faire en
sorte que leur sport faut qu'ils aient
un plaisir dans leur sport d'abord
qu'ils aillent le plus loin possible
parce que par définition et son
compétiteur et pour certains ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent mais il n'y a pas ce
devoir de retour d'ailleurs je fais une
parenthèse
souvent on dit pourquoi untel untel qui
vient du club pourquoi intel intel n'a
pas de l'argent au club
moi j'ai toujours considéré qui faisait
leur carrière et qui ne devait rien à
personne
ça c'est la première chose qu'ils n'ont
pas à devoir le faire ou à devoir vous
donner à qui que ce soit maintenant
maintenant ça paraît tellement
intrinsèquement liées au sport on
parlait alors de l'entreprise on parlait
alors du sport et des valeurs ça que ça
engendre et qu'on transmet c'est celle
du partage c'est celle de la solidarité
pour c'est vrai qu'on pourrait imaginer
aisément que ce soit surtout dans le
sport qu'on puisse trouver un maximum de
gens qui soit dans le caritatif dans le
don dans la générosité mais le fait de
devoir non mais que ça soit finalement
un réflexe pour eux ça me va bien
et puis une dernière chose ce qui me
gêne un peu c'est l'idée selon laquelle
on ressort son image par le caritatif
terre que de plus en plus maintenant on
se sent un peu obligé cette fois ci
c'est par un devoir mais on se sent
obligé de se montrer dans des oeuvres
caritatives pour montrer qu'on a une
image celle qu'on veut donner
donc ça me gêne qu'on soit obligé de le
faire ça me gêne pour soi qu'on doive le
faire une fois pour l'image et une fois
parce qu'on a récupéré de l'argent et en
même temps c'est tellement ce qu'on
transmet comme valeur que ça serait bien
qu'il le fasse voir sans le dire et je
vais jouer je rejoins complètement moi
j'ai dit oui mais je rejoins
complètement ce qui dit ça doit pas être
une notion de devoir ou d'obligation de
je le fais pour obtenir quelque chose
pour qu'on me voie ou pour que ça donne
une telle impression mais c'est plus
j'aime mon sport je peux peut-être faire
quelque chose pour que et j'apporte une
contribution qui est pas forcément une
contribution financière tout le monde
enfin je veux dire un sportif n'a pas
forcément à donner ses gains mais
des fois ça peut on peut défendre des
causes avec en faisant finalement peu de
chose juste en se montrant présent voilà
plutôt dans ce sens là le devoir valeur
pas l'obligation et le devoir
ils ont quand même sauf finalement il
yal qui a raison qui a tort même si se
rejoignent d'accord j'ai quand je
reviens du niveau de notoriété comme ça
quand ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas été
complet il ya deux choses que j'ai donc
pas seïf hydrique
il faut déjà premier autorisé en tout
cas comme ceux des acteurs comme les
personnalités politiques
moi je dis faut qu'ils en aient envie
première chose parce que on entend en
longtemps et on voit régulièrement des
athlètes qui sont appelés à intervenir
au sein d'entreprises ou eux et puis une
fois qu'ils ont fait leurs interventions
x ou y
les mecs disparaissent il n'y prenne
aucun plaisir et ça se ressent dans ce
qu'il dégage et est donc pour moi vos
relations anales envie de le faire il
faut le faire si on n'a pas envie faut
pas se forcer
et c'est pas parce qu'il ya un chèque de
x ou alors qu'on sait du canada tca
caritative c'est pas le but n'est pas de
prendre un chèque mais quand on vend
quand ils vont en entreprise parfois
c'est pour prendre un chèque
s'ils n'ont pas envie de le faire pour
pas qu'il le fasse parce que derrière ce
ne sera que du négatif qui vaut ce
qu'ils vont dégager
je pense donc que ça se verra mais je
suis en bien sûr ça va se voir ça ce
transpirer
et donc scellé cette seule chose que je
trouve voilà qu'il faut quand on défend
une cause il faut que ce soit il faut
qu'on comprend qu'on ait compris la
cause aussi faut qu'on ait compris
l'objet de l'association qui a qu'elle
défend et chose que les athlètes ne sont
pas toujours
nous ne s'est pas toujours le cas pour
tous les effets raul il ya quand même
une notoriété quand même marché et chez
les sportifs voilà messi ronaldo serait
connue par plus de 90% de la planète
sont les études
voilà footballeurs comme ronaldo il ya
100 millions de fans sur facebook
85 millions pour éviter qu'ils ont
voyagé et anale non voilà qu'est ce
qu'il y avait une notoriété qui peut
utiliser un produit d'épargné
je suis opposé aux trois mois parce que
même si effectivement contre quand on
est devenu un grand champion on en est
le premier contribuable ça c'est sûr
c'est le fruit de nos efforts c'est pas
vraiment c'est jamais construit tout
seul il ya forcément soit le pays pour
le coran présente un contribuer il ya
quelqu'un qui nous a tendu la main
quelque part pour que ça soit possible
on sait jamais fait tout seul ça
n'existe pas on fait pas tout seul avec
ses deux mains jamais donc à un moment
donné il ya quelqu'un ou quelque chose
ou un organisme qui a donné pour qu'on
puisse le faire
et moi je pense que le devoir il
intervient à ce moment là donc pour moi
oui c'est un devoir de trop de
transmettre ces valeurs là parce que à
un moment donné il ya des gens qui ont
misé sur nous à un moment où c'était
utile pour nous deux que ce soit fait
donc pour moi c'est rendre rendre la
pareille de le faire et c'est prendre
ses responsabilité de représentants de
la nation quand on parle des grands
champions que que de faire ces choses là
c'est moi je pense est normal
inadmissible il faut passer par là c'est
pas tout à fait la question que j'aille
comprise un mois j'avais compris est ce
que les
sportif de parle en notre qualité et
leur image les vins sud ouest et de
rendre mais c'est l'apparition des bugs
mais non mais n'oubliez contre caritatif
donné à des associations caritatives
c'est de ça dont on parle et alors ils
ne doivent pas pour moi ça devrait être
naturellement que ça doit venir
naturellement 2003 non mais là on parle
d'autre chose
un grand sportif de la france qui
représente la france
il a le deux mois de bien la
représentait bien sûr en plus de m merci
on a obligé de terminer l'émission c'est
le timing de l'émission qui sait la fin
on en parlera la prochaine fois des
sabres laser à voisins-le-bretonneux
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve le jeudi
22 juin pour un nouveau numéro de si on
parle de sport
à bientôt sur tv fil 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]